[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Captain Marvel post-credit scene
video there were two post-credit scenes
one mid-credits scene and then one
traditional post-credits scene after all
of the credits so if you're going to see
the movie again make sure you stay
through the entire credits will do a new
round of the IMAX take a giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Marvel post-credit scene on the video
obviously careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the movie in the theater
yet because we will be talking about
what happens at the end of it so here we
go first post-credit scene or
mid-credits scene this is the Avengers
end game scene where you pick up some
time shortly after the events of the
snap after this moment here where
they're all sitting in the ashes of all
their friends they go back to the
Avengers base Captain America still has
his beard Black Widow still has very
short blonde hair so it doesn't seem
like that much time has gone by they're
looking at all those heads-up displays
that you see during the Avengers end
game trailer where they're counting all
the people that they've lost the number
counting the dead just goes up and up
and up and Captain America just can't
believe all the people that are dead
they're still shook by what happened
they're still trying to make sense of it
but separately they've also acquired
Nick Fury's pager they don't know what
it's for
they've bypassed the power supply
Captain America Black Widow Hulk and war
machine are in the room
the others start questioning the logic
of the pager Black Widow isn't sure
what's going on what is this about we
need to learn in Captain America just
says it was important to fury so that
means it should be important to us
they're just trying to keep it running
black widow says we need to find out who
fury was trying to contact in its
captain Marvel's jacked up pagers so
obviously she turns around and with no
sound at all Captain Marvel is just
standing there right up in her face with
slightly longer hair in a really
disheveled looking costume that she's in
at the end of the Captain Marvel movie
and says where's fury boom slam to black
so just to be clear Captain Marvel is
still in her same uniform but it looks
like she's seen a lot of battle in the
last 20 years
she's not time-traveled the fact that
she has a much longer haircut just let
you know that time has passed for her
but the way her powers have changed her
physiology just slows down the aging
process she's infused with space stone
infinity stone energy so she ages more
like Thor but this whole time the reason
why she had never come back before is
because she said only call me in an
extreme emergency samuel l.jackson
explained after the movie that because
he had the Avengers he didn't call her
because he felt like they were enough to
deal with all the previous threats in
the other Avengers movies the first
Avengers movie and then Avengers age of
Ultron while this has been happening the
past 20 years Captain Marvel has been
attempting to police crease crawlspace
and end the kree-skrull war it's taken
this long like she says at the end of
her movie tell the supreme intelligence
that I'm coming I'm coming to end your
war and end the lies so no matter how
powerful she is that's still an enormous
task we'll talk more about that when we
get to Easter eggs second post-credit
scene is goose the cat in samuel
l.jackson office inside the shield
facility puking up the tesseract on his
desk earlier in the movie when they find
out that dr. Lawson aka Marvel in the
MCU was using the tesseract and had it
stored on her research ship cloaked in
outer space they need a way to sneak it
off the ship and Nick Fury and the
others are too afraid to touch it with
their bare hands because they're not
super human so they're worried that the
tesseract will hurt them somehow while
they're arguing about it goosed the cat
promptly opens his Maw his tentacles
come out because there's a floor can
they're kind of like aliens with a giant
mozz eats it in a really funny moment at
the end of the movie when Coulson is
asking Nick Fury about what happened to
it and how things got really crazy Nick
Fury just makes a joke
looking at goofs the cat saying that
he's sure that the tesseract will
resurface at some point knowing that
eventually the cat will pie just throw
it up which it does in that post-credit
scene number three the actual timeline
of the tesseract in the MCU I know
there's a lot of questions because
people were worried they're breaking
continuity this is the way it went down
start to finish with the creation of the
tesseract all the way to Thanos crushing
it and putting it in the Infinity
Gauntlet sometime in the ancient cosmic
history of the universe someone uses the
space stone to create the tesseract
shortly after that Odin finds out about
it comes into possession of it puts it
in his treasure vault in Asgard for
safekeeping this is all before Thor is
born and Loki has adopted ancient
history of Asgard sometime later after
Odin has been in possession of the
tesseract he takes it to earth for
unknown reasons and leaves it there
that's where it comes into possession of
that Church in Norway the people that
worship the Asgardians as gods they
enshrined Odin's jewel quote-unquote in
the elaborate carving of the world tree
in that Church where it stays in
safekeeping for thousands of
years until Red Skull finds it at the
beginning of Captain America First
Avenger at the end of that movie the
tesseract sends Red Skull to Vermeer
where he eventually dies and becomes the
guardian of the soul stone the tesseract
falls into the ocean when Captain
America crashes his bomber very shortly
after the end of World War two Howard
Stark retrieves the tesseract and begins
to study at learning of its limitless
potential for clean energy he tries to
find a way to exploit it for years but
can't quite crack it then in conjunction
with the US military in the government
he forms project Pegasus this
underground research facility the Dark
Matter reactor that eventually becomes
the base that they blow up at the
beginning of the first Avengers movie so
if it wasn't clear the project Pegasus
base where all these records are that
they're running around in during the
movie where Wendy Lawson was working
that's the same base that Nick Fury
blows up at the beginning of the
Avengers movie Howard Stark was critical
in building that facility so he was part
of the early days of that sometime in
the late 80s when he lost and comes
along comes onboard the project and
tries to turn the tesseract into a clean
energy source for faster-than-light
engine no one on earth knows that she's
secretly a Kree Marvel a scientist
that's set by the Supreme intelligence
who found out that the tesseract was on
planet earth and wanted it for their war
with the Skrulls when Marvel is killed
in the accident that gives Captain
Marvel her powers the tesseract just
stays hidden in her research ship until
the end of the movie where they go to
retrieve it is eaten by gusta Kat then
thrown up soon after haha funny
post-credits scene at which point Nick
Fury takes the tesseract back to the
project Pegasus facility where it stays
in containment as they continue to try
and study it for their Phase two weapons
program remember that was the big plot
point during the Avengers movie where
Captain America and Iron Man learned
that they had been trying to use the
tesseract to create weapons that was
sort of the project that they adopted
after they decided that they couldn't
use it to create a faster-than-light
engine shortly after that Erik Selvig
comes to work for them he opens the
briefcase and shows it to him you see
Loki sort of shadowing him saying who
that looks interesting then you have the
events of the Avengers movie Loki uses
it to come to earth with the express
mission of taking the space stone back
to Thanos
he's unsuccessful in Thor takes the
tesseract and Loki back to Asgard places
the tesseract back in Odin's vault
till the events of thor ragnarok loki
steals the tesseract at the end of that
movie then hands it over to Thanos at
the beginning of Avengers infinity war
to save Thor's life
Thanos crushes it takes the space stone
it has at the beginning of Avengers
endgame he still has the gauntlet in all
of the Infinity stones so that is the
timeline for the tesseract in the MCU so
no timeline errors no continuity
problems Howard Stark just had the
tesseract up to the point at which he
founded project Pegasus with Wendy
Lawson then Wendy Lawson just became the
custodian of the tesseract hopefully
that explains what's going on I know
there's a lot of other questions about
plot points and continuity and how her
powers work and what's going on with
Avengers endgame don't worry sometime
before the end of this month we'll get
another Avengers endgame trailer where
we get a little more footage maybe
they'll start including Captain Marvel
in that because remember what they did
with the first ant-man movies
post credits scene for Civil War it was
a scene of them in that bunker there
after they had stolen away with Winter
Soldier that scene actually happened
towards the middle of the Captain
America Civil War movie it wasn't the
beginning it didn't happen before so
that means that this scene of Captain
Marvel answering her page in the
Avengers facility could happen sometime
a little bit later in the film but just
remember Captain America has that long
beard Black Widow has the short hair so
wherever it does happen during the movie
it seems like it's relatively early
because then cap at some point we seen
the trailers shaves the beard black
widows hair grows a little bit longer
then later in the movie we see more time
goes by some sort of time jump because
her red roots grow out so you can
actually use people's hair to chart the
timeline a little bit but just remember
that they digitally alter a lot of
things in trailers so there could be
some misleading stuff in that
post-credit scene just to make you
wonder about when it happens in the
timeline of avengers endgame leave all
your avengers endgame or Captain Marvel
video requests in the comments below
I'll do more Easter Egg videos this
weekend so be sure to go see the movie
while you wait for everything click here
to learn about all the Marvel movies
coming after Avengers endgame and click
here to rewatch the new Game of Thrones
season 8 trailer a billion more times
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]